BRIAN:  SENATOR MITCH MCCONNELL
AND CHUCK SCHUMER DEBATING ON
THE SENATE FLOOR IF THE SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER UNVEILS HIS
PLANS FOR A PHASE III
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF, SO WHAT CAN
WE EXPECT IN THIS AGREEMENT WHAT
HAS TO BE IN, WHAT’S STILL UP
FOR DEBATE HERE TO DISCUSS IT
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE CENTER
JOHN BARRASSO.
SENATOR THANKS FOR JOINING US.
SENATOR MITCH MCCONNELL CAME UP
WITH A PLAN AND THEN THE
DEMOCRATS CAME UP WITH A
PLAN NOW IT’S TIME TO GET
TOGETHER.
THEY DOESN’T WANT TO STICK WITH
POOR LEADERSHIP.
HE WANTS TWO DOZEN, AND SOME ON
THE LEFT ARE SAYING WE’RE NOT
GOING TO GET ANYTHING DONE WITH
A GROUP THAT SIZE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> WELL THIS IS A RESCUE
OPERATION FOR OUR COUNTRY.
WE NEED IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR
PEOPLE ALL ACROSS AMERICA TO
MEET US WITH DIRECT SUPPORT AS
WELL AS DEALING WITH THE
MEDICAL COMPONENT OF THIS.
I THINK WE NEED ALL HANDS-ON
DECK, THE MORE SENATORS INVOLVED
IN DISCUSSING IT, THE BETTER WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF TASK FORCES WHO
ARE WORKING ON IT, WE’RE WORKING
STRAIGHT THROUGH THE WEEKEND, WE
NEED TO GO BIG, WE NEED TO BE
BOLD ON THIS , AND IT NEEDS TO
BE BIPARTISAN, BRIAN.
WE HAVE TWO CRISIS RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE THE HEALTH CARE CRISIS
AND THE ECONOMIC CRISIS, AND
UNTIL WE GET THIS MEDICAL CRISIS
BEHIND US, WE’RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
RECOVER OUR ECONOMY.
BRIAN:  SO ARE YOU GETTING
PUSHBACK ALREADY UP TO $1,200
PER INDIVIDUAL, FOR 2,400 PER
COUPLE, AND THAT BE FOR A COUPLE
THAT MAKES I BELIEVE UNDER
$175,000 IN THE $75,000
THRESHOLD, AND A $500 PAYMENT
PER CHILD, IS ALL THESE THINGS
STILL BEING BROUGHT ABOUT?
>> THAT’S ALL PART OF THE
DISCUSSION.
WE KNOW WE HAVE PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN EVERY
COMMUNITY FROM THE PLACES IN
WYOMING ALL THE WAY TO NEW YORK
CITY AND CALIFORNIA, WHO THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN, ARE OUT
OF WORK.
BUSINESSES HAVE HAD TO SHUT DOWN
SO WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
PEOPLE, THE FAMILIES AS WELL
AS THE BUSINESSES,
BECAUSE WE WANT THOSE BUSINESSES
TO CONTINUE TO BE VIABLE, SO THE
FOLKS WHEN THIS PANDEMIC
PASSES CAN HAVE THOSE JOBS AND
THE JOBS WILL BE THERE BUT THEY
NEED IMMEDIATE RELIEF AND DIRECT
SUPPORT NOW.
BRIAN:  I HEAR YOU, BUT HOW TO
DO IT AND WHO GETS IT?
THE AIRLINES, THEY NEED
50 BILLION TO SURVIVE.
THERE’S PUSHBACK FROM THE
DEMOCRATS SAYING WE AREN’T
GOING TO GIVE IT TO THESE BIG
CORPORATIONS WE GOT TO GIVE IT
TO THE PEOPLE, CASINOS NEED
MONEY, SMALL BUSINESSES NEED
MONEY AND HERE IS A STATEMENT
FROM THE SCHUMER PELOSI
LEADERSHIP GROUP.
WE’RE BEGINNING TO REVIEW
SENATOR MCCONNELL’S PROPOSAL AND
OUR FIRST READING IT IS NOT ALL
AT ALL PRO-WORKER AND INSTEAD
PUTS CORPORATIONS WAY AHEAD OF
WORKERS.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> WELL I WANT EVERYBODY TO
REVIEW IT AND THE STANDPOINT OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS THE GOAL THERE
IS LOANS ONLY, NOT DIRECT
SUPPORT, BUT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES, AND THE FOLKS WHO
WORK FOR THEM, IT BE DIRECT
SUPPORT, SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
MAKE THEIR PAYROLL, SO THEY
CONTINUE TO KEEP THE DOORS
BASICALLY READY TO BE REOPENED
BY PAYING THE RENT AND THE
ELECTRIC BILLS, THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF AMERICA IS
READY TO BE BROUGHT BACK TO LIFE
ECONOMICALLY ONCE THE DISEASE IS
DEFEATED.
BRIAN:  JUST HOW YOU DO THAT AND
HOW YOU GET IT DONE IF TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE IT SEEMS LIKE
VOTES ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE CAN EXPECT
A BILL?
>> WELL THE GOAL IS TO HAVE
SOMETHING READY BY MONDAY.
WE’LL WORK ALL DAY TODAY,
TOMORROW, SUNDAY, I’VE ALREADY
MET WITH A COUPLE OF SENATORS
EARLIER THIS MORNING.
THIS IS GOING TO BE AN ALL
HANDS-ON DECK EFFORT TO TRY TO
GET THIS DONALD GET IT TO THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
MONDAY IS THE GOAL, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE EXPECT US TO ACT AND DO
IT IN A BIPARTISAN WAY.
BRIAN, THINGS ARE USUALLY PRETTY
SLOW UP HERE.
WE PASSED THAT FIRST MEDICAL
RELIEF BILL THAT GOT SIGNED
EARLIER THIS WEEK, $100 BILLION
BILL TO HELP ADDITIONALLY AND
NOW THIS IS THE THIRD PART OF
WHAT WILL LIKELY BE MORE TO COME
AS WE GO TO RECOVER THE ECONOMY
AFTER THE MEDICAL COMPONENT IS
BEHIND US.
BRIAN:  LASTLY REAL QUICK,
SENATOR FEINSTEIN HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF DUMPING A WHOLE BUNCH
OF STOCK RIGHT BEFORE THE STOCK
MARKET BAILED OUT.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> I’VE SEEN THE REPORT.
I DON’T KNOW THE DETAILS.
I KNOW WE’LL HEAR MORE BUT LOOK
WE ALL KNOW THE RULES AND WE ALL
KNOW THE LAWS AND WE ARE
EXPECTED TO LIVE BY THEM.
THAT’S WHAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
EXPECT.
THAT’S WHAT WE EXPECT OF ONE
ANOTHER AND I EXPECT TO HEAR
FROM EACH OF THEM LATER TODAY.
BRIAN:  PLEASE DON’T LET THESE
CORPORATIONS BUY THEIR OWN STOCK
WITH THE MONEY WE GIVE THEM EVEN
IF THEY ARE LOANS SENATOR
BARRASSO.
THEY GOT TO PLAY THIS GAME
STRAIGHT.
>> ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THIS IS WE’RE ALL IN, WE NEED TO
ALL BE IN THIS TOGETHER.
IT IS A RESCUE OPERATION FOR
AMERICA, WHICH MEANS MEDICAL
TREATMENT, IMMEDIATE RELIEF, AND
THEN RECOVERY AS SOON AS WE CAN
GET THE MEDICAL PROBLEM SOLVED.
BRIAN:  ABSOLUTELY AND YOU’RE A
DOCTOR AS WELL AS A SENATOR.